they said it couldn't be done Lawrence
McKenna will never get views yeah I bid
you click bit how many people are
putting you in their totals now yeah
it's amazing I did it first I made you a
star I remember when we first started a
podcast and you had to call it the Life
of Brian to trick people into clicking
the podcast it was about me
[__] it I'm famous get used to it
[Music]
genuinely big good here Spencer and Alex
have separated they put out their
Instagram posts they put out the tweets
very United in doing so you can tell
that they're still friends and they're
coming out of the same still love each
other
it's lovely yeah it's not worked out for
whatever reason we don't want to pry but
I would just like to say very sad here
that yeah love them both lovely people
Spencer I don't really know Alex but I
know Spence is lovely and so if he's
close with someone then they must be a
nice person to what Alex has always been
really nice to me
sure has been very friendly to me as
well yeah and Thomasine she's being
hugely important to like the success of
Spencer like all the editing or
everything that she's brought at the
table just sad and sad when people break
up sometimes it's sad therefore the
frames videos what why would you do why
are you trying to drag us through an
emotional wreck of it all right so
lovers
shots good or good they still go
training together that was sad when
couples trained together and then yeah I
decide when you reach the end of sort of
that time with that special person
someone wrote on Twitter she was hot
it's so [__] weird how people talk I
always just thought they're like the
perfect couple
yeah I mean you thought I could take
aspects of our no I just thought I'll
never I'll never be like that because
I'm too up and down to really have bad
days but you also just a [__] but you
have great days yeah but I'm your best
day you're like Spencer on your worst
day I love is like a roller coaster
life is just how long I need you stop
Spencer that one's for you Alex
you're both lovely people and I hope you
meet someone and you're both very happy
yes you're both great people since day
one
he's always referred to as our audience
as a ladies and gentlemen no ladies and
gentlemen I watch a new path just kids
me yeah but you can't be a boy girls
what would you call [__] and one cuz
right brilliant brilliant
what the [__] I'll be honest I didn't
get to this point in the video so I
don't remember this well that's one of
those people who he thinks of a lot of
ideas thank you be fair he was the one
who start the whole YouTube boxing thing
but some aim when you think of a lot of
ideas yeah some of them are just gonna
be a skirt dachshund Jeremy Lynch in a
loop ring now this is how it's gonna
work the first person to land a big
accurate punch on their opponent wins
the round ah if only that was the rules
for our fight Joe you might have done
better right hook by Jay tree another
trap I trigger toward not answering so I
haven't thrown a punch yet Joe needs to
start throwing as you stitch injure up
there half of you being used against Joe
Weller now Lynch almost getting in there
but he doesn't and wella fires back with
that jab he's finally learned how to use
it's yeah because I'm JJ clearly finds
joy funny yeah there's this animosity
between the two which is like they both
like each other but they both want to be
each other I remember after the press
conference talking to Jo Jo where it was
like he felt like Joe was trying to ruin
his career because of the mental thing
yeah you're on stage you're trying to
one-up each other you're saying anything
you can't decayed in each other's head
all of a sudden it's taken as JJ's
having to go everyone for that you
haven't got Joe he's never forgiven them
for that fully it's a shame look cuz I
they make good [__] like together
Keith ness is forgiven sin here alright
so here we go for round two boys and
girls
well obviously trust me to do commentary
yeah that would annoy me a little
doesn't this would have been a tricky
piece of this would have been really hot
and to be honest with you but big fun oh
my these are big swigs carded for both
boys can you imagine being the kids at
this leisure centre on that day you know
when there's every leisure centre has a
bit were you wonder into the cafe and it
overlooks the whole your game your chips
and gravy and yeah that's probably you
tubers punching themselves and a
slippery floor usual isn't it while the
boys are fighting there's gonna be Billy
aka the referee throw it in different
foreign object hmm okay I wonder what
foreign object John with the light
during our fight
so basically well I did a response to
this Joe nice to saw a video Joe nice to
saw a video Joe nice is her video was it
ghost this is a ksi unreleased song I he
doesn't want anyone to hear but because
he's decided to make this video I'm
gonna play it to you the club I see
giving his ringer Rob this is the wala
that I like the the Wella that makes me
[__] Holmes taking like it is such a
good pistol but I don't think he's done
this for [__] years
[Music]
got my mama looking cool I [__] that
[__] with my King Kong [__] this kind
of shows just how far judges musics come
as well Larry very Wow yeah yeah not
like this is terrible and I'm sure you'd
admit that he is where we improved
Norgan see he hasn't improved it's so
condescending confused by that song and
how's Joe habit they used to work
together on music because Randolph
brought the brown horse yeah yeah of
course no credit poor Randolph and to
work with all these YouTube is trying
actual legit credit for things obviously
he was more like I was a fan of him
growing up so when that match came about
it was like 100% whereas I going against
anyone else it really has to be someone
that I really give a [__] about like be
in my passion is making videos write it
like just these so that boxing video I
made recently I don't really care about
winning what really happened in it I
just like making sort of like the
production
it's like nerdy as that sounds like
that's my thing I've got to respect that
I really respect that yeah totally
honest yeah at the end of the day
training for months on end if you're not
about boxing and you don't want to be a
boxer training at the top of the tree
you've got Logan and JJ who are gonna
make huge money yeah there's a reason to
get in there and there's this whole
thing about who's number one between the
two of them it's a real fun rivalry
there's nothing left for what I do in
the boxing thing then he went in there
he did his best we all know what
happened
Fairplay tour he give it a good go he
had the balls to do it like he says
there would need to be someone who was
like a Jake Paul or someone like that
was really Logan Paul it was really
worth him doing it absolutely you know I
mean I've seen this JJ did have
something the responded oh but I'm still
using the fight as a way to be like Joe
yeah
obviously yeah you beat me but he is
such a [__] you can't it's hard to not
like his money
yeah I genuinely think well areas okay
with it though yes fine I know but I
think I don't think he's up at night
like caring that you lost the fight no
just in the day there's a phrase that
when people don't know how to react and
you've kind of got them they go WOW [__]
yeah I do have one more thing that I
could reveal to people so I hope we're
good I hope you're over it let's call it
a day all right what do you think it is
I think si scared of mice chaos eyes big
secret is that he is absolutely
terrified of Swiss cheese Swiss cheese I
waited 20 minutes for him to go Swiss
cheese is all you two supposed to be
thought-provoking like our great podcast
a mr. Brian you are so busy trying to
appeal to the [__] kids all you ever
talk about all the time is Oh
but will the eight-year-olds watch all
should we should we ever go up there in
the big blue house not this week Brian I
say not this week
this is how they could yeah this is what
the money miss oh let's have a go at the
Teletubbies no Brian is you putting bad
thoughts in the little kids imagine all
these kids going into nursery right can
we do at Rouge huge plays and the care
workers going I don't know what you mean
by true news there's an Australian
couple that I watch sometimes they're
very they're a bit too sweet and cutesy
though sure sorry what wouldn't be
coming down my erection [__] hell how
do we go from Spencer and Alex to your
massive no but look Nico look at them
they make a lovely couple you'll see in
a minute
I mean the lovely couple right don't
sexualize this brown
I think he is being very lucky what was
he like a six he's a [__]
eight-and-a-half yeah but
personality-wise tendons got it all in
there would you be honest with me I
thought if tomorrow
a woman like Peter came to and said I
want you to be my cane would you drop me
and everything else and go let's have a
guy who won't do a couple things I'm
chillin on the couch and I'm like let's
just watch some Netflix and order some
takeaway and [__] and she's like well
let's go and do this and film it the
night no no I just wanna have a [__]
chill out and not be a [__]
performance seal Jim ever me yeah yeah
you love flicking through videos with
semi naked girls in I wonder what I was
then probably a bottle of someone yeah
[Laughter]
look at happy they are these two have
such a happy life look she's always
smiling the nature of YouTube
relationships is that you you don't get
to see everything that goes on like
spurn and Alex are their perfect couple
in my eyes but obviously that's not the
way it's absolutely yeah they never did
a everyday life type thing but these
people do and other relationships on
YouTube do and I feel like if you commit
to a vlog regularly you kind of don't
want the rouse to go in but I think that
it would be healthy if these YouTube
couples were like after we had an
argument be like we've had an argument
this is what she thought this is what I
thought was really pissing us off yeah I
did like that one Casey and his wife
Candice did that they had a podcast
where they basically just laid it all
out what he did wrong what he did wrong
I thought it was good because instead of
just going doing the basic thing of like
we're either really happy or really sad
everything's really good everything is
really bad they weren't I was really bad
but there's how we made it good and this
is maybe a little bit too unrealistic
the point is that this as well there
will be some women or men watching this
and thinking why don't I have that yeah
and that's because you can never achieve
that's unachieved even they haven't got
what they've got no exactly this is the
Gillette commercial right I'm really
honest see what you think of this okay
is this the best a man can get
what so this is funny the best a man can
get used to mean the best of raise as a
mountain get now they've how good can
men be right is what this men can be
amazing or terrible apparently can't
hide from it's been going on far too
long
men do touch women's boobs that is true
inappropriately sometimes yeah making
the same old excuses so it's sort of a
phrase that's used to put down people
who go piss out of me or II you know it
made fun of me because I'm all men and
they out boys will be bought me boys
will be boys what that phrase means is
do you know when you were at school and
I always got into a fight with each
other or one of them kicked your
football over the fences a very boyish
thing to do but it will be boys yeah and
actually that's the difference because
we're talking about men here not not
boys boys only raise us
although boys do grow into men you've
got me on that one I have one net and
there will be no going back
because we we believe in the best in men
men need to hold other men that's Terry
Crews Cruz Terry's got a big face for a
lot of guys who are he's been in that
movie with so I still own all the other
big ones the Expendables Ben day was in
white chicks as white cakes I sort of am
he's the same guy who used to say it to
girls in white chicks you gonna need a
wheelchair yes that you [__] him but
now men need to hold other men
accountable but I mean I suppose men can
do POC recei 101 I guess so I mean it
was all because he was actin because the
boys watching today right your idea was
good your execution was [__] terrible
you know I said it I put a tree out just
saying you know this would never be
directed at women probably because they
don't have beards
yeah I don't need kids although they get
hair other places but right you know
that's so to use what you do that you
can say things to men that you can't say
about women and here highlighting every
bad you know thing men are known for and
then you can be better I mean no [__]
mate no [__] I've seen women on Twitter
going to bat for Allah and being like
yeah this is an REO that was replied to
one person in this string of replies nas
I because I all I said was give me one
example where an advert for women shows
women in the worst light possible in
every bad thing that they are known to
be doing right and then shows they can
be better to show me one example because
women are taught you very differently
women are built up it's all about body
positivity all of the good things is
there anyone out there going that's
annoying
I was just about to grow a pair on the
ass when she wasn't asking for it and
now I've seen the Gillette video I'm
thinking maybe not right and I was I was
really looking forward to touching her
ass yeah but now I've got the honey now
I've been given a conscience by Gillette
[__] hell we don't need a [__]
razor company telling us this it's just
kunti it's being put out there because
they knew was gonna trigger people
doesn't rig like me you need not
triggers at all I'm a journey
it's funny though that one key this is
yeah now it's time for a short apology
we'd like to apologize for the views
that Brian expressed last week about the
partner of Jeff Bezos I went on a bit of
a run last week about this man men often
CEOs a big companies get divorced the
women get off of a lot of money and it's
not contributed with generally that's
what happens people came up me yeah
right wanna be the guy who can't admit
when he's wrong now yeah I'm not that
guy
no apparently she did have quite a lot
to do with quite a lot beginning of
Amazon and also he cheated on her
that being allegedly I don't know how
much not the specifics in that case it
probably deserves favorite man yeah
maybe not half but a bit more so people
are calling me a misogynist even
comments I feel like I should defend me
so yeah go for it person who strongly
prejudice against women if I had to be
on this planet with only men are only
women it would be only women why just
sort of soft niche I don't then the look
after you and the kind you are quite
more loving than men you know motion I'm
not a woman here how can I hit women me
mum's one yeah do get annoyed that men
get shafted in divorces when they've
worked hard for their money
some of them others and I do think that
this is a thought system but that's not
how kind of woman's fault a little bit
but it's not completely the woman's
fault so I'm sorry if I came across that
way yeah look down the lens and say
sorry police in Phoenix are
investigating a possible sexual assault
at a nursing facility after a patient in
a vegetative state became pregnant and
gave birth so she's in a vegetative
state right she's laid there someone who
the family have trusted to look after
her most likely one of the care workers
as just as I'm trying to defend men it's
a difficult sell this stuff gotta be
honest with the important we just treat
them like the one monster that years and
not say it's masculine it you what this
also proves weirdly she's in a
vegetative state
yeah man or [__] anything she didn't
push the baby oh right the body
naturally will give birth yeah and you
know it just just shows the body's an
amazing thing doesn't it yeah spokesman
for Arizona's governor calls the
situation deeply troubling and promises
a new focus on patient safety a new
focus
listen guys less [__] the coma people
alright can we all just focus here this
facility is now under criminal
investigation as detectives try to
figure out who is responsible take a
look at the [__] nurses and doctors
make a meal find one of them the
[__] who care for her yeah we
might want to DNE yeah I will say this
though Jimmy Savile and this is genuine
think climbed in through a window - yes
in the words of Eddie Bravo look into it
yeah but Trisha Paytas was in the we
made you video by Eminem and now she
sorta does these shitty like the YouTube
you mukbangs sort of stuff where they
eat a lot of food and people sit and
watch and people love her for whatever
reason they love her he's also quite
overtly sexual sexual content she had a
bit of a runt let's check it out which
are two horrible situations in regards
to our horrible economy so the wall per
se is good she's doing so she's
supporting wall when your job is to sit
on a floor and feed your [__] face
full of [__] you can't really talk about
other people getting jobs and it does
pay attacks at home so is the chef well
done that she can't really talk about
that little [__] you know your job in
politics pepper yeah shut the [__] up
yeah well she's a comedian literally you
feed your [__] face people watch you
there are one two three four five six do
you think men masturbate to this oh yeah
yeah yes men must a bit of a lot of [__]
I should have been in Gillette advert
Tommy stop wanking you put her in the
Gillette advert the reverse way you
could just have her talking and then
Gillette at the end just go don't be
like that anymore and now be it that
would be the woman's push sheets with a
mouth wide open as well really annoys me
the fact that she's doing this on camera
and this many people are watching I feel
really bad for the fact that people want
to watch that like I mean I'm not saying
we make [__] Albert Einstein level
content he was a great filmmaker
tantrum yeah it's just [__] terrible
in the too much isn't it this [__]
shape who was Soulja Boy for those who
don't know what you boy blow up off a
big song and in Soulja Boy told him that
when lyrics mattered in the in the 2000s
of rap music and late night he went and
change that and made pretty [__] music I
was that innovator it didn't mean
anything anymore and you could just just
sort of do a hip-hop pop song he had a
one hit well done what was good is that
an opinion or is that effect I would
think it's a fact known fact how do you
think you cope on Breakfast Club I don't
mean being interviewed but how do you
think you would cope with hip-hop people
coming in and talking to you like [__]
like that I think I don't think I would
deal with it as well as Charla me and
does I think I would be a bit more like
I'll give you a back so I think you're
more like sha'lame and you're smart in
terms of you'll criticize the content
right but you won't you after the person
was I'll be a bit more like you're an
[__]
I was the Lawrence last week it was
funny yeah well it's fun to be me isn't
it not really I've got a new
appreciation for it was it was a good
bin Bryan I mean hatred for women thing
was tricky for a little while but I got
over it was gonna didn't we didn't do
that no no we did
why do you mean me I have a bigger
coming mythology boy came on what a
number one record to Drake beef
championships actually he was like
number one for a while yeah and it did
really big numbers like I said like I
think he did double the 619 album the
first song tell me what's really going
on Drizzy Drake back in this thing
already
was it that's so make Drake that was a
lot more like Soulja Boy but then he's
going to go up you make him drink dude
so Drake mixtapes we all know that we
all know that we ridiculous so that's a
soldier boy showing off that's
embarrassing there so an egg's getting a
lot of attention it's now the most liked
post ever on Instagram my name is beat
now a Kardashian some people are now
saying this egg the post of the egg
could be worth up to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars what house the
house the world record egg verify I
thought the whole point is has to be a
real person you have to work out there
it's a real egg or not these ways of
working out is the real
a 7.6 million yeah this is prob dumb
people or 28 million likes BAM leader
with an egg
I let said well cuz ironically normally
you beat eggs yes the eggs beaten
that's brilliant the idiot we have a
look at Kylie Jenner who would be Wow
do you like Kylie Jenner I mean she's
got a very fake face I don't like fake
faces cause all these girls are getting
plastic surgery they all look the same
and I don't want someone whose face
it'll be walking past us end of the road
you're like what same charge the same
woman yes I do appreciate it despite the
I do like that what what do you like
just big off so anyway there's a beer
well done well done you eggs we got him
already Stevie Wonder attempted a jump
shot actually should we yeah so Stevie
Wonder's not gonna do something he
doesn't want to he's just have a little
bit of fun you know Israel if you're a
blind man or you've got any kind of
disability and you want to attempt
something
don't [__] do it yeah I think what
Stevie Wonder's showing blind people
here by acting and being the person who
goes blind this is a social construction
I don't care if you if I can see the
ball or not I still want to play
basketball that's good for blind love I
actually was very superstitious well
done to the legend yeah
giving it some give it Stevie gone so
she's on the treadmill [__] no yeah
he's on a treadmill oh [__] well okay so
she's looking like she's doing it again
just no able-bodied see she gets back up
she's like did anyone see that don't
think that woman background saw this
probably just grab my stuff and just
turn this [__] off
no there was literally hunger no why are
you always looking at the ass
good business it makes sense I'm sure we
could pull something together I could be
the only pro fight one that shows very
likely yeah doesn't mean I love it out
[__] light that kid imagine he wins a
world title and like he was sort of
discovered on yuge it's not only that
it's the fact that he is basically
saying Frank can happen I would be on
the undercard how much we'd all be
supporting him yeah as well imagine
being the guy who was on the undercard
with him he's asked me to do one of
those what's it the munchies yeah that's
right
yeah I'm gonna get him so drunk before
we go I only I think I don't have to do
like a few minutes with him yeah yeah
I'm literally gonna have like a
two-month trailing oh yeah totally
cuz no ways I'm just gonna be covering
yeah all the basically going the ring
and just nah yeah you've got a triangle
you start it with a towel just just in
case yeah for that whole time just you
walk in the ring doubt that there's
always a murmur if we forget I just hold
on to his legs
wrestling to the floor and it'll lay on
them and then run I want to get your
thoughts on this family will pay 75,000
pounds a year to someone who can help
turn your sons into row footballers
listen to a lot of podcasts and and I've
met professional athletes and you always
find that early on there was someone who
changed the direction of their lives who
came in and educated them on the spot
amazing podcast with Rogan and my tyson
and for him it was custom auto who was
the old guy who are all the knowledge
and found this [__] great young man
who are all the power to put it into him
in boom you've got a [__] world
champion on you I respect the parents
for Billy for believing in their kids as
a sport in their kids absent going on
they must really want it for their
children so good for them 96 20 years
there's no one who can legitimately come
in that situation and guarantee that the
easiest way to do it now would be to go
to Spencer and go spend spend dogless
you are gonna be quite lonely now that's
me move it with he would laugh at that
yeah if you're not laughing I'm sorry
I'm sorry
yeah difficult time for us all if
there's one guy I know who I would say
would be the best person for this Alan
Shearer Jimmy Conrad Jimmy Conrad's he'd
be the guy I would love Jimmy Conrad to
be a Mary Poppins tight
Hajin Jimmy Conrad is very popular with
a burger ball Jimmy lock him in the
theater also yes in the most innocent
way and he comes in his own right guys
we're gonna play football that you want
to check Jimmy's content oh well put the
link in description or I love that guy a
guy he was the first person to believe
in me on YouTube I believe in him he's a
legend he may be the last Jimmy thank
you now have you ever been to Dubai no
right you're gonna want to go after this
ladies and gentlemen please fasten your
safety belts really see his eyes reading
the teleprompter oh this way as well
whoo in Dubai when what says like rich
Dubai Michael on my car it is the type
of pretentious [__] who'd love to come
oh yes the aircraft is the first group
state-of-the-art concept decks
helicopter and this is no ordinary
chopper Michael I love Holly smiled that
he said that eat because he thought of a
[__] so when he said chopper Michael
Aaron thought [__] and he knows these
people who wrote the script didn't know
that here we go and this is no ordinary
chopper
he is definitely thinking of a cog and
well you definitely [__] himself right
okay there's what that's one thing it
reminds me of have you ever seen this up
there this is an advert from a few years
ago also 2011 I think that was a prime
era for this kind of a bit okay they
said we heard the rumor oh really George
what rumor George what Robert you are
rumors your does it man just you know
you're doing their own wine this is an
aspect you're trying to sell white yeah
you're Manchester United yeah just cut
to Alex Ferguson and his little [__]
wine cellar getting pissed
that'll do it so that's what I want to
see them yeah yeah I want to hear him
say I made Giggsy yeah I made King I
want to hear him take all the credit
does that fit the image of a fine wine
no an old man ranting in a wines yes
right why cuz it's Alex Ferguson right
is a legend fine wine of a man
guys we have a problem the boss said
that's new devil is arriving we've got
some lines we need you to say can you
just literally say the words please
Thank You Wayne
guys we have a problem yeah the boss
says that's new the boss said that a new
devil is arriving it's weird that we
would have to strike as it Michael Lord
and Wayne Rooney and they'd both be as
personality --less as humanly possible
the look of concern or Giggsy literally
is more concern than Giggsy ever showed
than when he was rumbled for the years
of affairs he heard someone just shown
him right we have pictures be [__]
your brothers sister what oh we got that
we got the shot we're good wrap that's a
wrap everyone right explosion in the
ground Wayne Rooney's instant reaction
is something's off his wife was of such
a tone with him when you never react to
anything I say so
mmm I've had that I need a blow I use it
now for polonaise because the actual
wine isn't great quality that was a man
of Bolognese you know what time it is
food reviewer and you reviews on the
YouTube you never knew such a cool dude
I keep it so flat and do you know why
it's because I know whether to buy dad
booze
yo guys mm-hmm friends look normal
that's his idea of like a wacky wild
joke I mean he laughed so hard as he was
putting that in as well imagine you were
stuck even behind the great man
Oh imagine being in the same restaurant
and not even knowing it looking over and
just going the food reviewer can you
review a popsicle for me
I would say I look at a poster doctor
but it starts coming out wast and
they're always good from here they're
always good from here and it's a
surprise usually always good and you put
them together someone almost interrupted
here and he was like I'm the [__]
food reviewer you'll talk when I'm done
he's like The Godfather in the group so
someone goes I feel like isn't he just
customer look and I'm sorry yes [__]
told me yeah exactly
you know he is the Godfather of that
group now he's bringing him in bringing
them in he realized he rules me than I
am fest he needs other people to speak
do you know no he let them only one he's
huh de su does have a bit of a de niro
about him doesn't he he's got a little
bit of dinero look at that face that's a
very Robert De Niro face you know I mean
if Robert De Niro thought I know that I
want to save his poorly lit one good
lighting right it should be food review
you want him to be driving four hours to
the nearest BK I want an awkward
exchange with a [__] person at the
window yeah you know where he looks
embarrassed of how much is eaten yeah
yeah I said I want darkness hey guys
what's going on
reviewer today as you can tell by the
title I'm gonna be trying out the new
Burger King LP no chicken fries I'm not
a big fan and yet he's going to go and
try the jalapeno price off oh so that we
don't Huff exactly yeah I can't drive
there so that customer ones work at Stop
& Shop you'd be so where's that stuck in
shows absolutely
but you imagine him putting the step up
on the shelf and being like ahh recover
review that one day I might review this
later he when he walks around stopping
shop is like getting ideas constantly
for the videos you imagine all these
numbers going around his head sort of
different thumbnails you know how much
butter could add to that kind of thing
do you know what I mean I love it I'm so
tempted to say Jalapa now because that's
what I say
he's turning this into a conversation of
maybe I'm right
maybe everyone else is wrong maybe
Spanish is wrong at the end of the day
this is how I sit yeah exactly the food
reviewer does what he wants yes wait for
the eyes to get bigger look at him
that's his [__] face as well exactly
right and he also at the same time goes
Joe a panel was gonna be sick I think is
gonna be sick no he's just spitting it
good no wow oh that was the end of the
video you know what happened here don't
you something happened where he was like
can you watch it but anyway thanks for
watching this week's been good to have
you guys if you wanted the food reviewer
you got him you got him spit him food
out of his card or something we've never
seen before and there was amazing
renaming Jalapa knows yeah we talked
about a lot if there's anything you want
to talk about next week on true news let
us know in the comments we do have
podcast coming soon and I've taken a lot
of luck lately it's not easy I am NOT a
lot of these big guys with budgets to
pay
guestbook as I haven't got that kind of
money or they've got a lot of kids who
follow we do have a couple of very good
guests lined up on the podcast that
you're gonna love really good promise
you a really good one so stay subscribed
please hit the like button
and we say is there bye-bye